well well well if it isn't the mullet
muppets
mr theo vaughn morgan whalen huge fan of
both of you guys thank you very much hey
can you say my name right now
i didn't want to see the question and
ask
what song are you most excited about uh
coming up on the album
i listened to the three new songs that
came out as well as the other ones that
have been the singles
and just awesome awesome takes
so continue to do what you do and uh
yeah what song are you most excited for
and why
he does have a gang gang i'm sorry
you're the man
thank you thank you keep doing what you
guys are doing thank you brother thanks
for the question man i appreciate you
yeah thank you and uh he does have a
different accent so maybe that's
you know that's how they would save
money a lot of french fans dude that one
yeah that guy was from france somebody
said
was that guy really from france you
think or was he just saying that yeah it
was really
oh that guy from france he had a weird
sound who would just say i'm from france
i don't know
but you're right though maybe he lied he
could lie yeah i'm not saying he's a
liar sorry man
i'll say it he could be sarah
pretty good and i think the mullet goes
i think we got four different types of
what do you got about it back there
yeah it's growing out a little bit oh
you got that new york city mullet dude
that business
it's a little too long up top maybe if i
think if i combed it all the way down it
would look like that's
beautiful bruh you look like yeah you
look like a damn raccoon that's going to
prom
it's uh winter time and like wearing
this kind of [ __ ] makes my hair look
like a rat's nest but
it is what it is you know it looks great
man i think you got some beautiful hair
yeah
we're like four women dude i used to
have like jeff leopard hair
magazines oh you're it's beautiful hardy
you're doing great
my hat's already back on i'm like all
right anyway what about your what about
your game yeah
you got that verse i got that i feel
mine is a little bit more like women who
prefer the
company and women i feel like mine is
definitely
morgan's is more mullet yours is more i
feel like kind of uh
what is yours earn dude i don't know
well i when i get it trimmed up right
and let it sit down correct this is it's
outgrown i gotta get amy to cut it
it's actually bro it's actually a bullet
because i do it straight
i don't know i like that i like that the
better when i do it straight across the
top and let it drop
oh the lord will find you if you keep it
like that people aren't really beautiful
because i can put it back for a casual
set i wouldn't and
i like that that's real i would do that
and drink out of the bird bath in the
front yard dog you know what i'm saying
that's full
that's like almost like a british that's
like a british sort of uh
i did this before miley did it i will
say yeah sure
he did no i know i did and i know
miley's seen it
because my name gets dropped all right
and i know she said who's earnest what a
name and looked it up and saw my haircut
and said
they'll never know i took it from him
the majority don't he's trying to get
myself a song i'm trying to get miley
cyrus on the phone and figure out where
she figured out that's what i was just
gonna hear about that dude
golly i'm passionate
heated earnest i'm sorry i drank a
suicide on the way here and i'm
geeked up no you're i mean my aunt sally
dude right now honestly dude 100
and she's badass too when you borrowed
one of my dad's shirts one time to go
swimming in the pool
it was not made of wood
does she smoke virginia bro she smoke uh
medium-sized virginia's brush she's a
bigger guy
damn dude damn i look like aunt sally i
mean
she was beautiful too she won seventh
place in the um
beauty contest
but there were 30 interests there were
30 30 so man
there was 30 entrants dude that's top
third almost you know
dude lips come baby do it yes sir uh i
don't think we even answer that guy's
question
yeah yeah yeah well yeah it is favorite
what's your favorite what's your most
excited
you got it yeah where's the most excited
and we're gonna learn because i didn't
do it right
yeah what's the most exciting one man
damn morgan that's a that's a hard
question and
it is really and you shouldn't have to
answer something like that
well i'm not gonna yeah there you go
good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watches one
ah